we are at the very beginning of history
future generations will see us as the
ancients living in the distant past what
are the events that really could have
civilizational trajectory level impacts
and then finally taking action trying to
figure out okay what can we do to ensure
that we navigate these challenges and
try to bring about a wonderful future
for our grandchildren and their
grandchildren
given the fact that we're seeing james
webb telescope images all over the place
at the moment kind of seems like a smart
time to be thinking about far-flung
futures and potentials for civilization
and stuff like that
absolutely james webb is making very
vivid um and in high resolution
an incredibly important fact which is
just that we are at the moment
are both
very small in the universe
um and
also very early in it so almost all of
the universe's development is still to
come ahead of us
that's wild to think about the fact
especially on our time scales right you
know you think about 20 years as being a
very long time in a human lifespan and
then you start to scale stuff up to
continents to the size of a planet to
the size of a solar system or a galaxy
or the universe and it
it puts things into perspective
yeah well we're used to
long-term thinking being
on the order of a couple of decades or
maybe essentially at most
but really that's being very myopic
um i mean
how long has history gone on for well
that's a couple of thousand years homo
sapiens have been around for a few
hundred thousand years
the earth formed four billion years ago
first um the big bang was a little under
14 billion years ago
and
if we don't go extinct in the near
future which we might do and we might
cause our own extinction
then
we are at the very beginning of history
uh future generations will see us as the
ancients living in the distant past
and to see that we can just use some
kind of comparisons so
a typical mammal species lives around a
million years
we've been going for 300 000 years that
would put 700 000 years to come
so already on that by that metric our
life expectancy is very large indeed
but we're not a typical species we can
do a lot of things that other males
can't
that creates grave risks such as um from
engineered pathogens or ai that could
bring our own
demise but it also means that if we
survive those challenges then we could
last much longer again
where the earth will remain habitable
for hundreds of millions of years uh and
if one we one day take to the stars well
the sun itself um will uh only stop
burning in about eight billion years and
the last stars will be shining in
uh hundreds of trillion years
so on any of these measures humanity's
life expectancy is truly vast if you
give just a one percent chance to us
spreading to
you know the stars and staying as long
as uh lasting as long as the stars shine
well we've got a life expectancy of a
trillion years
but even if we stay on earth the life
expectancy is still tens many tens of
millions of years
and that just means that when we look to
the future and when we think about
events that might occur in our lifetime
that could impact that future that could
change humanity's course
well you know we should just boggle the
stakes that are involved
and when you talk about long-termism
that is
looking at the future as something which
needs to be taken seriously there is
this sort of grand potential for
human flourishing for human life for all
of the good stuff that could occur for a
very very long time over a very very
wide distance and we need to take it
seriously
exactly long-termism is about taking the
interest of future generations seriously
and appreciating just how big that
future
could be if we play our cards tonight
and how good it could be
and then from there trying to think okay
what are the things that could be
happening in our lifetime
like engineered pandemics like later
than human level artificial intelligence
like world war three what are the events
that really could have
you know
civilizational trajectory level impacts
and then finally taking action
trying to figure out okay what can we do
to ensure that we navigate these
challenges
and try to bring about uh you know a
wonderful future for our grandchildren
and their grandchildren and their
grandchildren and so on
it's nice to hear or to think that
you've been focused so much on
long-termism because i fell in love with
the precipice by toby odds that i know
you work with and
anybody else
he's phenomenal man but anybody that
reads that book especially the the
beginning the premise that he talks
about right and the premise is he he
believes that humanity is at a very
particularly unique dangerous inflection
point in between sort of prehistory and
our um
civilizational inheritance that we could
continue on and and be lovely and
flourishing with and in that first
chapter he talks about the fact that
the
huge vast
inheritance potential that we have
downstream from us
is it is crazily big and yet almost all
of the things that we do now
are focused on such a narrow time span
we're not thinking even the most
long-term of long-termism
projections don't get into the hundreds
of thousands or millions of years like
you're talking about
uh exactly we focus on this tiny window
and you know in many cases that makes
sense you can't control
what people in the year 3000 have for
breakfast
um but surprisingly there are things
that
we can affect now
that do impact people in the earth 3000.
where number one among those which toby
talks about at length
and where you know you can see the
precipice and what we are the future my
book is kind of complements to each
other absolutely uh both playing a very
similar photo
yeah one of the things that toby talks
about um at length there's ways in which
we can cause our own extinction
so obviously asteroids super volcanoes
there are natural risks that
could wipe us all out
thankfully we've actually done a pretty
good job at least of navigating
asteroids
spaceguard and nasa program just came
together spent
only on the order of about five million
dollars per year um but has basically
eliminated the risk of them asteroids uh
it's very very unlikely that we now know
it's very very unlikely that we'll get
hit by some kind of dinosaur killer uh
in the next few centuries
but we are creating new risks so the era
of nuclear weapons created
india of like new destructive power
and the next generation of weapons of
mass destruction could be considerably
worse again
um engineered pathogens could create
the ability to create create new viruses
that could kill
you know hundreds of millions of people
billions of people perhaps everyone on
the planet
and
if you know a
large bio weapons program starts up uh
focused on such things uh and we have
seen large bio weapons programs in the
past
that could be fairly dangerous indeed
and that's exactly the sort of thing
that we want to ensure goes to kind of
zero as a risk
so how are our actions now
important is it about investing in
uh trajectories that people move down in
the future what what difference does
what we do in 2022 have
in 20
022
yeah so
i think there are two ways of impacting
the long-term future so one is ensuring
we have a future at all such as by
reducing the risk of extinction or
reducing the
chance of civilization just collapsing
and then never recovering
a second way is by making the future
better assuming we do survive improving
kind of future civilization's quality of
life
and
on the first of these uh well one thing
we can do is carefully carefully
navigate new technologies that can mean
accelerating defensive technology
beneficial technology and it can mean uh
putting in policy such that we either
slow offensive technology or just choose
not to build it
so on the accelerating offensive
technical defensive technology
uh one thing for example is uh
far uvc lighting
where this is
um a certain small spectrum of light uh
if you implant the light into a light
bulb and uh it kind of
irradiates a room um just as a normal
light bulb does then it also kills off
the pathogens in that room
and this is very early stage research
but seems you know it's quite exciting
um i think
with some foundations i advise we're
going to be funding it to a significant
degree
where if this checks out if it's
sufficiently efficacious if it's
sufficiently safe um then we could
launch a campaign to ensure this is
installed in all light bulbs all around
the world we would have made it you know
very very hard near impossible to have
another pandemic
um and along the way would have
eradicated
uh
basically all the spillover disease
and you know that's pretty exciting
that's something that we can do
um by taking these risks seriously to
say
look we can have an enormous benefit
impact not just on the present
generation but on
the course of all future generations to
come creating a safer world for
you know the next generation
is
this a particularly crucial time do you
think in the history of the future
uh yeah i think there's good arguments
for thinking that we're certainly a very
unusual time
uh i don't want to make the claim that
we're necessarily at the very most
important time perhaps the next century
will be even more important um
and i think there's some hugely crucial
times in the past as well
but with a very unusual time compared to
both the history both history and the
future
one reason for this is just that the
world is so interconnected so
for most of human history or a large
chunk of human history
there just weren't wasn't a global
connection there were people in the
americas people in asia and africa
people in australia and they just didn't
know each other at all even within the
land mass of eurasia you know in the
early the first couple of centuries a.d
the han dynasty and
um the roman empire
they comprised about 30 of the
population each but they barely knew of
each other they were like you know tales
that one would tell of a distant
civilization
whereas now we're global and we're
interconnected and that means that say
you have a certain message that you want
to get out there in principle it can get
out to the entire world
or in a you know more darkly if you want
to
you know achieve conquest and domination
you can potentially do so over the
entire world
and in the future again i mean we were
talking about galactic scale thinking
and uh
the james webb telescope in the future
we'll be disconnected again if one day
we took to the stars we're on different
solar systems
then even to our closest solar system
there and back communication would take
eight years
and at some point in the very distant
future well actually different galactic
groups will be disconnected such that
you could never
communicate between one another although
i'll caveat that's very far away indeed
about 150 billion years
so hopefully we're still going by then
but no guarantees
um so that's one the fact that we're
just so interconnected is one way in
which um
[Music]
uh the work like one way in which the
present time is so important
um
well what i'm going to say is so unusual
um and seemingly important because it
means that
you know we can have this like battle of
ideas and um
competition between values and
if one value system like took power then
it would take power over everything
and uh that's pretty
you know
potentially pretty worrying
a second way
in which the present is so unusual is
just how fast technological progress is
happening
so for almost all of human history when
we're hunter gatherers um economic
growth uh which is you know one measure
of technological progress uh
was going about basically close to zero
very very slow um accumulation of better
stone tools um spear throwers
things like that
uh agricultural revolution meant that
sped up a little bit developed farming
better farming techniques but we're
still growing about 0.1 per year
over the last couple of centuries we've
been growing more like two or three
percent per year in the frontier
economies
now can we keep that and most of that
growth is driven by technological
advancement that enables us both to have
more people and for those people to have
better material quality of life life
now how long can we keep that going for
uh you know sometimes you get this idea
of oh well future science is just
boundless we can never
never come to the end of it
but we've only been going properly for a
few hundred years since the scientific
evolution
and it seems to me hard like if we go at
this pace well
at some point we'll have figured out
pretty much everything there is to
figure out
but we can think about this economically
as well where uh
if we keep growing at two percent per
year
after ten thousand years
uh civil because of the power of
compound growth
uh civili you know the world economy or
the total economy would be ten to the
power of 89 times current um
civilization there's a very big number
and to put it in context uh
there are only 10 to the power of 67
atoms within a thousand 10 000 light
years
so we would need to have an economy a
trillion times the size of the current
world economy for every atom within
reachable distance and that's just
extremely implausible
um i really just don't think that's
possible
and so that suggests
we're at this period of rapid
technological growth
and rapid technological advancement that
cannot continue
and
that means we're moving through the tech
fee an unusually fast rate and that
means just a lot of change it also means
that
we're at a kind of unusually high
density period in terms of developing
technology that could be very important
used for good or um
very harmful you know used either to
lead to civilization or collapse to end
civilization uh or
for to allow kind of certain ideologies
to gain power and to influence how the
course of the future goes
early on in our history we weren't
moving sufficiently quickly to be able
to develop anything that would be that
much of a surprise because it was
iterated at a much slower rate
potentially or it seems like
further into the future
not only are we going to have such
advanced technologies that any dangerous
technologies can probably be mitigated
at least a little bit but also again
it's going to slow down you're going to
have this sort of s-shaped curve right
like flat to hockey stick to then start
to flatten off again and both of the
relatively flat areas of that
not much change which means therefore a
relatively low amount of risk i'm going
to guess this links in with nick
bostrom's ball from the urn
thing right that there's just fewer
balls that can be picked out of the urn
when the change isn't occurring so
quickly
exactly so if we're thinking if we're
asking is now an unusually important
time
well yeah uh nick bostrom has this
analogy of um technological progress is
like throwing balls from an urn
and if you pick a green ball then it's
like a very good thing if you pick a red
ball then it's a very you know bad thing
it's maybe it's even catastrophic
we're picking balls from the urn just
very quickly
um i mean i'm actually not sure like
most balls are both green and red
depending on which way you look at them
uh most technologies can be used for
good or ill fission gave us nuclear
reactors it also gave us the bomb
um
but you know we're picking balls out of
this urn at
a faster rate than we did for almost all
of humanity's history or and that we
will do for almost all of humanity's
future
even if we don't go extinct in the next
few centuries what are you talking about
when you say trajectory change
terrific so uh we've talked so far about
kind of safeguarding civilization
ensuring that we just make it through
the next few centuries
and that's been the kind of main focus
of discussion when it comes to
existential risk
but we also we don't want to merely make
sure that
we have a future at all we also want to
make sure that that future's as good as
possible we want to avoid horrific
dystopian features we want to try and
create a future that is positive and
flourishing
and so trajectory change refers to
uh
efforts that you can make to make the
future better in those scenarios where
the future lasts a long week
civilization lasts a long time
and
how can you do that well a number of
ways but i think
the
most likely way is to influence the
values that will guide the future like
the moral beliefs and norms
where
uh
you know at the moment we are used to
living through periods of great moral
change you know the gay rights movement
emerges in the 70s and it's only a few
decades that um
you know gay marriage is uh legalized
and that's like you know rapid moral
change compared to history
um but that might change in the future
um this
moral change that we fast model change
that we know of might end in the future
because often
uh
set moral world views or ideologies they
try to
in their nature they often try to take
power and they try to lock themselves in
so we saw this with uh the lies of
fascism with the nazis during world war
ii
hitler's night of the long knives gets
into power crushes the ideological
competition similarly with stalin's uh
purges gets into power clutches the
competition similarly with um pool pot
uh
and the khmer rouge
because
if you're an ideology and you want power
then you want to ensure that that
ideological competition goes away
and my worry is that this could happen
with the world as a whole
where
you know in the 20th century we already
had two ideologies um
fascism and
stalinism that
really were aiming at global domination
um and
i think
you know
luckily we were not in a state where the
world came close to that
um but it's not like that's a million
miles away in terms of how history could
have gone
and so then when i look to the next
century well one major worry would be
for example
there's an outbreak of a third world war
uh which i think is more likely than
people would otherwise think uh we're
used to this long period of peace but
that really could change i think it's
something like one in three in our
lifetimes
and the result of that could be single
world government single world ideology
and
depending on what that ideology is like
could be very bad indeed you know
something like what you got in 1984
george orwell with the handmaid's tale
like that word
and then finally i think that
with the development of
new technology and in particular ai uh
that ideology could last persist for the
very long time indeed potentially just
as long as civilization does
so value lock-in isn't necessarily a bad
thing
as long as the values that are locked in
are values that we would want over the
long term
uh right so if you
if it were the case that the values that
got locked in were the best ones the you
know the ones that we would all come to
given sufficient reflection and 10 000
years to think and reason and empathize
machine extrapolated volition has been
utilized correctly and all of that yeah
exactly yeah
um then
then that would be okay
however we should appreciate that we
today are very very far away from having
the light model views i mean it would be
this amazing coincidence if all of
history in through all of history people
had abominable model views supporting
slave owning or patriarchy or
uh
atrocious views towards uh criminals or
people of different sexual orientations
or people of other nations
um but we in the early 21st century um
nailed it in west western countries yeah
we've figured it all out
be very surprising indeed and so what we
want to ensure is that
we don't end
moral progress kind of too soon
and
if
anyone kind of came to power in the
world we're like yes i'm going to lock
in my values now i'm going to ensure
that the things i want persist forever i
think that would be very bad i think
there'll be a loss of almost all value
we could achieve because we need to keep
morally progressing into the future
that's what i was going to say
is there an argument here to be made
that optionality or whatever the word
would be um or the regular change of a
particular moral structure should be
something which is optimized for that
even if you were to potentially get rid
of a
moral structure that was more optimal
and switch to one which is less optimal
than that the fact that you've baked in
the ability to switch helps you to
mitigate some of the dangers of having
complete lock-in for the rest of time
overall
that's exactly right we want to have a
world where
um
we can change our moral views over time
and in particular where we can change
them over time um
in
uh
light of good argument
or
you know empathy or just like
moral considerations
and there might be many points of
lock-in in the future so
the design of the first world government
would be such a point of lock-in uh
first
um space settlement as well like you can
imagine there's a race dynamic and
everyone's just trying to get out into
space to claim those resources as fast
as possible
um
i actually think that you know a couple
of examples of lock-in in the past were
uh
the colonial era where you got this like
single kind of world view suddenly just
spreading all over the world kind of
western christian
uh world view
earlier times were the first world
religions where again you've got this
kind of bubbling of ideas then it
compresses into you know the sanctified
holy book and um then persists for
thousands of years
well also actually just the lies of homo
sapiens as well there used to be many
homo species we used to have a diversity
of human species and then there were
only one because one was a little bit
more powerful and you want to
um
you know predictably that it means that
the competition
um
is to slide
what's your problem with that so what's
your problem with the happy birthday
song
um thank you for asking me about that
that's not even in the in the book uh
what you're the future does not discuss
happy birthday
so i use the example of happy birthday
as an example of bad lock-in
to illustrate the fact that
even the fact that something becomes
universal does not mean that it's
necessarily like the right solution
as it were like the best state of
affairs so happy birthday is by far and
away the most sung song in the world
it's um the song that's used to sit to
recognize someone's birthday um in
uh
at least many of the major languages
and it's terrible it's like it's pretty
slow so it's like a little bit like a
dirge um the emphasis is on the u
two u
sorry so the emphasis is uh not on the u
which you should expect
um it's on the two which is like why on
the
position doesn't make sense
uh but then it also has like an octave
leap um
like happy birthday it's like and no one
can sing it so everyone's because people
are singing at different ranges
um so this is meant to be like a
communal song you know your family gets
together so you want a song with like a
really pretty small kind of melodic
range but instead it has this interval
and it means that like everyone just
suddenly changes key
at that point and then like now like
half your family are singing in one key
and half your family is singing in this
other key and it's just a cacophony
and there's no reason at all that it
couldn't be much better you can go on
youtube for people creating new versions
of happy birthday that sound much better
um and why did that happen well there
didn't used to be a happy birthday song
in fact the melody was for a different
it's called good morning to all i think
um but um
in
uh i think it was the early days of um
radio glamophones and so on um
i think perhaps like that was a mo what
i call a moment of plasticity so little
moments in history when things could go
one way they could go another way and we
can really have an influence over
um
what what direction happens but then
after that moment of plasticity there's
a kind of ossification
and so at that moment of plasticity
perhaps any of these songs could have
like
become the one that like gained the most
popularity
but once happy birthday is the most
popular song
um once it's known that that's what you
do to sing happy birth to recognize
someone's birthday well then you're kind
of locked in it's very hard to switch
from that because if i start singing
some different melody then everyone's
like what is this
and in the case of happy birthday it's
probably just you know we could
uh create
you know there could be some government
dictat that says okay we're all gonna
stop singing happy birthday because that
doesn't make any sense we're gonna sing
this different melody instead and
perhaps that would work it's not a
sufficiently important issue that i
think that would happen
some things like that have happened in
the past so
i think it was sweden that used to drive
on the left side of the load but its
neighbors drove from the right and so
they had one day
uh where they just switched they were
like okay we're also going to drive from
the right side of the road as well i
think it was 1978 and they had this huge
kind of
government campaign about it they had
like songs about it
um
though a big song competition the winner
of which was called uh
get to keep to the right svinson um and
it was successful they actually managed
to switch from being locked in to
driving on the left side of the road to
driving on the light side of the road
in the case of happy birthday i don't
expect that to happen
um but yeah happy birthday illustrates
how
the fact that this
song became so widely known
um
does not at all and culturally that's
almost culturally universal
does not at all suggest that it's the
very best thing
um that it's the best way we could have
sung happy birthday and i think happy
birthday has an important lesson about
future dystopia which is that model
norms and model means they can take over
the entire world without necessarily
being the best ones and i think we're
living a moment of plasticity now
um
with respect to what are the moral
beliefs of our time
that may not occur in the future if we
end up with this like single world
culture whether that's through conquest
or just through the kind of merging of
different ideas
and suddenly just everyone believes that
x is right and y is wrong
then what's the pleasure to change from
that um i don't think there would be
much pressure
and
if those views are wrong
if it's like the melody of happy
birthday and not the melody of some
better um song
then that could be very bad and that
would be a bad thing that persists for a
very long time what it shows is the
power of culture to be able to enforce
norms a lot of the time when you think
about the future and potentially bad
outcomes you think about the 1984
dictatorial bureaucratic
evil world government in tall buildings
telling people that they're supposed to
do something but one of the most
powerful enforcement mechanisms is
social approval and disapproval and just
grandfathered in expectations about what
you're supposed to do and what you have
one of the biggest problems you come up
against is when the people that are in
charge the bureaucratic organization or
the government or whatever
when they maybe even try to change
something for the better
and that runs counter to the flow that
you've got going through the culture
that's when you get uprisings and
revolutions sometimes kind of like
idiotic ones but the point is that
culture is so important we saw this i
use this example all the time we saw
this with the word woke so think about
the fact that walk was originally used
uh in rap songs then it kind of got
weaponized
utilized and adopted by people on the
left that wanted to identify someone
that was kind of socially aware and
cared about social justice issues and
then very quickly no one needed to
mandate that woke was going to be the
sort of thing that you didn't want to be
associated with but all of the comedians
and satirists and people online managed
to culturally enforce a norm where woke
became such a toxic term that you didn't
need to tell people not to use it no one
wanted to be associated with it because
it was just such a an uncool word well
what's cool why did it show me the cool
mandate or the cool policy doesn't exist
simply enforced by norms
yeah i mean there's just a huge amount
of
uh what humans do
is determined by yeah these cultural
attitudes just what's high status what's
cool and what isn't
and
you know we can see this so take
conspicuous consumption the fact that
uh people
like to show off how rich they are and
that can be you know across many
different cultures that is used
um as a way to show like
um you know how successful you've been
there are different ways of doing that
that are cool in different circ in
different societies over time so it
could be buying fast cars having
expensive watches or if we go into the
past um having very nice fabrics or
things like that
it could be owning slaves so in the
roman empire um the more slaves were the
status temple some roman senators had
thousands of slaves
um it could be philanthropy so this is
at least true to some extent in the
united states that engaging in
philanthropic activity is a way of
demonstrating conspicuous of conspicuous
consumption
and
which of these do we have
i think it's largely a cultural issue
very largely a cultural issue and that
really matters because whether
the demonstration of conspicuous
consumption which is i think you know
just human again human universal
whether that's done in a particular
culture through philanthropy through
buying fast cars or through
slave owning makes a very big difference
to the well-being of the world and i
certainly know
i certainly know which i prefer
and i think yeah social scientists are
only really starting to appreciate the
importance of culture
in the last few decades it's the sort of
thing that hasn't gotten enough
attention because well it's kind of
ephemeral um it's like you can't
quantify or measure it
as much as perhaps other things like
laws or
economic matters exactly
but over the course of like this book
just more and more i got convinced that
culture is an enormous force it's almost
it's generally culture that influences
um political change the other way around
if you get political change without
cultural change then um
that often doesn't go well
and in the book in what we are the
future i
focus
in particular on the abolition of
slavery
which
when i was kind of you know before
writing this book i would have thought
is just clearly kind of an economic
matter
uh
something that was kind of inevitable as
um
our technology improved slavery was just
no longer
kind of viable means of production
but i think i was wrong actually i think
that the primary driver of the abolition
of slavery throughout the world was a
cultural change and that was actually
based on people considering model
arguments and making changes on the
basis of model arguments
um and i think in the future we could
have
uh you know equally large changes that
could or not could not occur based on
what moral arguments are present
i've got a fix for the happy birthday
problem by the way
uh which is hit me so
we can't i'm not strong enough in my
mental capacities to change the actual
tune but you can
safeguard yourself from not being able
to do the octave by starting the song
one key lower than you think that you
need to everybody should do this
everybody starts belting out happy
birthday pretty close to the upper bound
of where they can go in terms of melody
no no no no bring it back give yourself
some headroom that's what you need and
then when it comes to that when it comes
to that keychain
you can nail it yeah yeah exactly
exactly you've got this sort of
beautiful
sound
you heard it here first life hacks for
everyone if that's it if there's one
thing that you take from this podcast
forget forget about the future
generations
sing happy birthday in a better tone
that's you that dude i'm telling you
that's it so yeah there we go you've
saved my life thank you um
i think
it's really interesting to think about
what what cultures and and stuff lock in
over a longer term but presumably this
means that we need to safeguard
civilization from a bunch of sub-optimal
futures and you've got
three different ones extinction
uh you've got global civilizational
collapse and you've got stagnation so
starting with uh extinction what's the
like
are we gonna go extinct like what's
what's gonna happen
yeah i think probably not um
uh so
in general you know it's hard to kill
everybody thankfully um
uh there are eight billion people in a
very diverse area of environments with
diverse societies um
and thankfully there are very few people
in the world that really want to kill
everyone
um
so the scenarios where that happens i
think
um
something's gone really pretty badly
wrong but it's not zero at all
so
um if we just can consider pandemics
what's the risk of
an engineered pandemic that is a
pandemic that's not from natural causes
but that is the result of design in a
lab where we already have technology to
improve
the destructive power of the viruses now
and that's just getting better and
better every year
and so
you know it's not very long that it will
be quite widely accessible that we'll
have the power to
create viruses that could kill hundreds
of millions billions of people maybe
even more
what extinction risk would i put of that
maybe something like point five percent
um essentially um
and much higher that there will be some
engineered pandemic that would kill
uh very large numbers of people maybe
that's like twenty percent or something
in a um by the end of the century
uh and that's just far too high
um
like far far too high
uh
because there are things we can do so i
mentioned for uvc lighting there's also
early detection so we could just be
monitoring wastewater all around the
world scanning it for um
dna
uh ignoring human dna and
seeing is there anything new in here is
there something we should be worthy
about and if so then we can act
kind of immediately
there's also just more advanced personal
protective equipment so
masks that of just
you know super protective not just like
you know the cloth masks you get but
full head things that would ensure that
if you were a key worker you would be
guaranteed to avoid infection that's
something we could be working on now as
well
so yeah this is a just
how we respond to this is contingent
it's kind of it's up to us um we can
choose to get that risk
kind of yeah way down to zero where that
ought to be
what's your opinion on nick bostrom's
vulnerable world hypothesis
uh so it is a hypothesis so to explain
the hypothesis is that
there could be some technology in our
future
that
gives the power
to destroy the world to basically
everyone in the world
um
and if so then it would seem like
it would be very likely that the world
would end pretty soon and he gives the
analogy of imagine if it was
as easy to create let's say a doomsday
virus as it is to just put sand in a
microwave
um then it just seems like we wouldn't
last very long because there's just so
many actors each making their own
independent choices
that uh
we would just
um
someone at some point would do so
uh
i think it's very unlikely to be honest
that the future looks like that
um the main reason that is that um we
just ban technology all the time
um
so
there are many technologies that we
don't like so take human cloning or
something
we could clone humans now if we wanted
to
and we choose not to um on ethical
grounds because it's um taboo and that's
kind of globally enforced
um in his essay um
on the vulnerable world hypothesis nick
kind of thinks nick's you know
if we were in this vulnerable world
would that mean that the only solution
would be
some very powerful surveillance state
uh
i think i think like no obviously that
would be like a really bad outcome too
um and
what we can do instead is just like have
strong international norms about
um
what technologies we
do allow to develop in which we don't
where um
yeah one is that
humanity is at least somewhat good at
kind of recognizing risks and taking
action on the basis of them and actually
in general being quite cautious with
respect to new technology
and then secondly technology is often
used for defensive measures as well as
offensive and so in general um
uh
you know in general i think the
vulnerable world hypothesis is it's
possible that it will occur in the
future
but
i think i'm a little more
optimistic than perhaps nick might be
given the uh risk or potential future of
an extreme surveillance state which
would be one potential solution to try
and constrain the degrees of freedom
that people can
do [ __ ] with whatever it is that
they've got um
can you see
a potential human future where an
effective long-term civilization is
basically
incompatible with democracy
i mean you could
so in what we are the future i talk a
lot about this is why the kind of
considering both values side of things
and
like risk side of things is so important
because
you know if you're only focused under on
the extinction side of the spectrum then
you might think okay we need some
undemocratic civilization
that can monitor everyone's behavior so
that no one can pose a risk to the
future of uh civilization and to be
clear nick boston toby old they don't
believe this but this is a kind of
a straw man view that you could come
away with
but then you've got this authoritarian
state
that i think has lost most of the value
that we could have had
um it's not just about making sure that
the future is long it's also about
making sure that's good
um
and so
you know
is the ideal governance of the distant
future democracy i don't know maybe we
can do something much better
um democracy would have been unheard of
uh
you know
for most of
most cultures throughout history
uh you know perhaps there's something we
haven't even thought of the on
reflection
uh we would think is an even better mode
of governance
um but i think i'd be very worried about
something that's more authoritarian
precisely for the reason that i think we
could easily lose um most value in the
course um as a result of that
where
you know the great and actually quite
fragile thing about liberal democracy
that we have
um
in places like the us and the uk
is just that you've got a great vibrancy
of debate and discussion
and
therefore are able to kind of drive
forward
model progress people are able to like
have moral campaigns people are able to
criticize the views of people
in power
and when you think reflect on kind of
human psychology that's like a
surprising thing
um and the fact that it's actually quite
rare in history should make you
appreciate that um
it's really something i think should be
treasured and fight and we should find
protect
um
and so yeah anything that's like
oh we need like strong
really strong kind of government in
order to reduce risks of extinction even
further and i'm generally like look can
we get 90 of the risk deduction
by other means and i think that often
you can
if you're concerned about extinction
presumably more people on the planet
would spread the risk more would make
complete extinction more difficult
because
the virus or the ai or the asteroid or
the super volcano or whatever simply has
got more work to do and for every human
that you add there is a potential chance
that they may survive and there may be a
few of them and then maybe they could
repopulate what's your view on whether
or not the world has too many or too few
people in it
uh it's a great question um and there
are considerations on either side of the
ledger so it's a very common
kind of idea that are too many people
resource depletion and climate change
and you shouldn't have kids because they
will contribute to climate change
um but i think those are and you know
it's true i contribute to climate change
um
through my life uh if i were to have
kids they words as well
um
but that's only looking at one aspect of
human
of what people do
because people do good things too and
they innovate and they uh
you know effects model change um they
contribute to infrastructure pay taxes
that benefit all of society
um i'd also say they just if they have
if someone has a sufficiently good life
that's just
living is good for them as well and
that's the sort of moral consideration
we should take into account
um but then yeah you're right actually
having more people um i mean
so actually yeah so i'll go back a step
for those reasons i actually think that
on balance
um
we should have more people rather than
fewer
um the benefits from an additional
person in particular via
both technological and model innovation
um as well as the benefits to them kind
of
outweigh uh the negative effects
especially given that you can you can
counteract those negative effects so if
you're having a child you can offset
their carbon emissions and actually you
can do so for you know a few hundred
dollars a year it's very small
fraction of the cost to have a child
but then how does having kids
putting aside climate change how does
having more people in the world
impact extinction risk
it's interesting lots of considerations
on either side so you're totally like
that
it spreads the risk we've got more
people in more diverse environments and
that makes us safer
um
and it's actually
on a little unclear to me whether
like in the world today this year
uh is extinction risk
higher or lower than it was a thousand
years ago now a thousand years ago we
couldn't have um
[Music]
uh
you know couldn't have blown ourselves
up with nuclear weapons but the
extinction risk for nuclear
you know at least with arsenal sizes not
with kind of future potentially much
larger arsenal sizes
um
extinction risk is pretty hard and
that's partly because there's just
extinction is really unlikely i think
and that's partly because there's just
so many people
in the world today and we have like
you know we have technology that can
protect ourselves
whereas a thousand years ago well there
was you know there was a vest of
asteroid spikes and it's not clear that
the world would have been able to come
back from that
um
however
i think that most of the extinction
risks we face
you know having a difference between
8 billion people and 10 billion people
it's going to be pretty small like we
already have it basically all the
inhabitable areas of earth and that's
the much bigger consideration compared
to
sheer population size um
the biggest consideration i think is
this is relates to stagnation where
it's well you know it's relatively
plausible to me that
technological progress will slow down
over the um over the coming century and
centuries to come
um basically if we don't if ai doesn't
speed it up then i think there's a good
chance it slows down
and
that's because we're just
not able to add more and more searches
to work on r d so
you know further technological progress
is just harder and harder and harder the
more we do of it
um
but we in the past we've solved that by
just adding more and more people doing r
d and like trying to do technological
innovation
um that's by both just having a larger
population so we have eight billion
people alive today um
it was
i think 200 years ago we had a billion
people
um
but also increasing the proportion of
people devoted to ireland
and we know that population is going to
like peak maybe by about 2050 and then
afterwards decline
maybe as late as 2100 we're not we don't
really know
and we just there's only so far you can
go by
increasing the
um
proportion of the world of your
population devoted to r d
and
that does suggest and if we stagnate a
period a very risky period when let's
say we have very advanced bioweapons but
not the
technology to defend against them i
think that would be a bad thing from the
perspective of civilization it would
increase the risk of us going extinct
and in that respect having you know
there being more people would be helpful
it would give us a longer leads time
would you know help further
technological progress
um okay i've spoken for quite a long
time but that being said i don't think
this is like a huge issue either way
can you dig in a little bit more to the
risk of technological stagnation
you know
why is it that there's kind of an
embedded growth obligation within
technological progress
uh yeah so
that was uh pretty quick
so
many people who think about the long
term
who focus on the future they're often
pretty bullish on economic growth
and the argument for this is like oh
well it compounds over time
um
you know if you're
uh getting
you know even just
increasing your growth rate by like one
percent over 70 years means you've kind
of made people on 70 years twice as rich
as they otherwise would be
it's a huge difference and it compounds
over time
um that's actually not a reason why i am
concerned about technological stagnation
because
uh you know as i suggested earlier i
just don't think you can have economic
growth that compounds for very long
periods of time that's you get to the
situation where you've got 10 to the
power 89 civilizations for
worth of output and it's just this just
doesn't seem plausible so instead at
some point we're going to just plateau
and
that means that if you speed up economic
growth now well then you get to the
plateau a little bit earlier and that's
kind of good into the intervening years
but not good over the long term or like
makes no difference over the long term
so one way of putting this is that i
think that
in general tech progress is kind of
kind of inevitable it like probably will
keep happening
maybe just a faster or slower rate
however stagnation would be very
different
and that's where
it's not just that growth slows but we
just stop growing all together
um or even the economy starts to shrink
uh
where we're just like not inventing new
things that are improving people's
quality of life
and
that i think could be quite bad
um if we're at this period of high
extinction risk
so
as an intuition pump suppose the
technology had completely stagnated in
the 1920s
so we reached the 1920s and then after
that there's no more innovation ever
would that have been good would that
have been sustainable
and the answer is no i think
if we'd stayed at 1920s level of stack
of
technology the only way we could have
supported civilization is by burning
fossil fuels and burning them
indefinitely until we burned all of them
um
that would have obviously caused like
extreme levels of climate change and
absolute catastrophe and also then we
would start to regress because we just
could no long we would have run out
fossil fuels and
um
we would no longer be able to power
civilization it was only by
further technological development that
gave us clean sources of energy like
nuclear power
and solar panels
and i think we could enter similar
unsustainable states in the near future
where again bioweapons are the main one
where
imagine okay now we're at 2050 levels of
technology we have advanced bioweapons
the sorts of things that in principle
could kill everyone on the planet but
not the technology to defend against
them
and now imagine we're at that level of
technology for a thousand years
i really don't rate our chances in that
world um
the risk even if it was low even if it
was just one percent per centually well
over a thousand years okay ten thousand
years hunt you know
the risk will add up and over the long
run we're almost certainly doomed
so we need that that consideration
suggests that
we need to at least in a measured way
kind of navigate our way through the
time of pedals the time of heightened um
existential risk so that we can get out
the other side and be sufficiently
technologically advanced that
uh
we aren't facing risks of catastrophe
just every year that add up over time
and instead have a position of
yeah what my colleague toby or calls
existential security where actually
we've gotten risk to a very low level
indeed yeah you want to get to sort of
x-risk mastery in one form or another
one of the things i always thought about
when i considered long-termism
especially after toby's book was
well why
why aren't the smart people in x-risk
campaigning for
unbelievably slow technological
development uh let's say that the earn
ball
analogy works and that there's dangers
with every new technology that you
develop
why not take 10 000 years to add in
another line of computer code right to
the to the ai that we're doing why not
but you know if if
what we've said is true and that there's
this basically limitless endless
duration for the potential of humanity
and yeah we need to get off earth within
two billion years or whatever the oceans
are going to boil but we've got time why
not
mandate or somehow enforce an insane
slowing of technology but it sounds like
one of the reasons that you can't do
that
is because you need to be able to
continue the conveyor belt of
technological progress in order to
protect ourselves from some of the
negative externalities of previous
technologies that we've already locked
in their existence of is that right
yeah i mean you make it sound like
there's like that place conveyor belt
okay is that is that not kind of how it
is
like well we've already started i mean
we now have you know
uh close to 10 000 nuclear warheads
ready to launch we're running that risk
every single year
um
and so hopefully there's a state
in the future that does not have such
high risks
and then we can just like stay in that
state of technological advancement
i should say that yeah i'm pro-tech
growth not everyone who endorses
long-term is by any means
um other people actually would want
technological progress to go more slowly
and more sustainably one thing we all
agree is we want certain technologies to
be slowed and others to move faster what
would be some examples of those
well uh again that things are often
easiest we haven't talked much about ai
but things are often easier to talk
about in the bio this case
where
this far uvc lighting that
if it works like safely satellites as a
room that's a defensive technology let's
have that as fast as possible
technology that allows you to redesign
viruses
to make them more deadly
let's just delay that
how about we do that in the future and
not just now um so and that's an idea
that nick boston calls differential
technological progress
so basically we all endorse i think
almost everyone would endorse that part
of time but then if we're talking about
tech or economic growth as a whole
should we go faster should we go slower
um
i lean on the faster side other people
would lean on the slower side
some people think that with ai in
particular we should really just be
trying to slow that down enormously if
we could um perhaps even just say like
look there's certain sorts of ai
technology that
uh we shouldn't allow like human cloning
like
in the same way that globally we don't
allow human cloning
but the main thing is just you know when
we're taking action
we need to consider
the tractability of what we're trying to
do
and i think it's extremely hard to slow
down
tech progress or economic growth as a
whole for the world as a whole
so let's say you know i'm i become an
activist i dedicate my life to doing
this and i convince
the uk to stop growing
doesn't make a difference in the long
term because all the other countries in
the world are going to keep growing okay
let's say i managed i'm a superhero
activist managed to convince um
you know 109 i've actually forgotten how
many countries there are in the world
but i convince every country but one to
keep
this just stop growing
well the last country keeps growing
before long it's just become the entire
world economy
um because if you've got compound growth
even if you're a small country growing
at two percent per year when all of the
other countries are stagnant
um within a couple of hundred years then
you will be the world economy and you
and the activism of those other all
those other countries
um will have been absolutely for naught
yeah and that's how i feel about the
kind of de-growth movement in general
which comes from a very different um
perspective kind of environmentalism
is
whether or not it's a good idea um and i
you know i tend to think that the
sentiment is not great but whether or
not it's a good idea it's also just
ultimately futile because it would need
to be a global effort and i think
given the
you know given the just
next level of difficulty we're talking
about in trying to do that there are
just better things we could be doing
such as accelerating the good tech
delaying the bad tech
it's a combination of a lack of a god's
eye
perspective and ability to deploy stuff
with some sort of malthusian trap and a
tragedy of the commons for the future
it's like all of that kind of mixed up
together to create this sort of
terrible terrible potential
yeah exactly and in general
you know one thing i really always want
to clarify with long-termism and work on
existential risk and the stuff that
what we do with effective altruism in
general and
also what i'm talking about and what we
are the future is that i'm proposing
action on the margin so it's like take
the world as it is
have a perspective on the world as a
whole
and however sources being allocated
should we check like
in what way are they misallocated should
we change them a bit
so when i'm advocating for long-termism
i'm not saying
all the resources should go to
positively impacting the long term
what i am saying is that at the moment
um
you know
0.01 percent of the world's resources
are uh focused on
representing and trying to defend the
interests of future generations and
maybe it should be higher than that
maybe point one percent that would be
nice maybe even as high as one percent
and so
similarly
if we're thinking
oh how fast should the world go or not
in order for that for the action
relevant question is like what should i
do should i try and speed it up or slow
it down on the margin that's the actual
relevant question not this oh what you
know if i could control the actions of
everyone in the world what should i do
because i don't i don't all we can ever
do is make this little difference on the
margin
what do you think about the volume of
attention that's being paid to climate
change
uh
over my overall view is enormously
positive about it
so
you know when you look at
uh different model traditions over time
it's actually remarkably of a concern
for the future is like remarkably aware
um
surprisingly like you know for the book
i was really i went to be like oh i want
to find you know christian thinkers
talking about the distant future and
like what we owe future generations and
uh hindu thinkers and buddhist thinkers
and confucians
and it
you know it's not like i did the deepest
dive but it was kind of surprisingly
hard
um
there are actually more thought in kind
of
um
indigenous
philosophy such as the other koi
um
but yeah then but certainly kind of
secular um post-enlightenment thought
it's like surprisingly there
and then over the course of the you know
20th century and then certainly the last
few decades we've had this enormous
upsurge from the environmentalist
movement that really is standing up for
future generations and they've seen kind
of one part of this which is focus on
you know stewarding resources especially
other revocable losses like species loss
and a particular problem of climate
change
and
i really feel like oh wow this is just
this amazing and like again kind of
contingent thing that there is been
there has been this groundswell of
concern for
um
how our actions could be impacting yeah
not just the present day but also
um
the world we leave for our kids and our
grandkids
and then
the thing i just want to say on top of
that is like okay yeah this is this
great model insight
um
and
that moral insight makes you concerned
about climate change here are a bunch of
other things you should be concerned
about that's i mean that really is the
main takeaway from reading toby's book
and he's got that uh table of the
chants within the next century of
something happening in a supernova
explosion is one in a 100 billion or
something like that and a super volcano
is one in 10 billion or something
and you start to move your way down and
you get toward climate change which i
think is either one in 10 000 or 1 in 1
000
over the next 100 years
and then you get to engineered pandemics
and unknown unknowns and ai safety
and it's one in ten and i think the
overall risk is maybe one in six
so
when i read that it it did
it does make me i understand your point
right that
anything that encourages people to think
about the future generally of the planet
and of humanity is smart
but i worry that there is a little bit
of a value lock-in that's going on here
where anything that detracts away from a
focus on climate change is seen as
almost like heresy
and that all of our future existential
risk conversations have been completely
captured by a conversation about climate
change dude
five or seven years ago the only people
talking about ai safety were getting
laughed out of a room like conferences
utterly things i mean i was there it was
like the early drafts of nick boston
super intelligence i was part of these
seminar rooms and i was like this young
guy trying to figure out um
what it's you know
what should i be into or buy and i was
like this is i mean i was in i was
curious and i was helping and we're
having conversations it was also it felt
very very laughed out of the room now
it's kind of yeah now it's much more
mainstream that that's my concern and
that was that was the takeaway from
toby's book and and also
one of the reasons why i think that i
know that you guys do testing on
messaging and stuff
and i really really think that that's
one of the most important areas look at
me bro sciencing my way into stuff that
you guys deconstruct very very
fine-tuned on a daily basis for me i i'm
so compelled by the ideas that came from
nick's work and toby's work and your
stuff and anders and you know like pick
your favorite existential risk
philosopher
yep and it blows my mind that that
hasn't
made
even a fragment of the impact of a
swedish girl shouting at
adults on a stage and it it i find
myself being less drawn and almost
triggered sometimes
by the
environmental movement because of how
much attention is paid to it and how
little attention is paid to other x
risks that i think should take priority
uh for sure so a general thought of just
if someone's saying
my cause is x and it's the only thing
that matters and everything should be
determined in terms of my like how it
impacts my cause that's just like social
media does not help with this um but uh
yeah that is just
like systematically um
not a good way of thinking and it and it
happens
one thing
uh
that
writing the
book like what we are the future has
made me
appreciate is just that like
chain model change takes time
so if we look at climate change so okay
now it has i mean yeah it's interesting
i see i listen i hear climate change and
i feel kind of inspired by it when i'm
like okay cool give us a few decades and
we're gonna be maybe we're going to be
there
where
concern about the climate
you know it actually goes back a really
long way so the first quantitative
estimate of
the in the impact
of emitting co2 goes back to a
climatologist called sventsvant arvinius
in 1896
and his estimate was actually pretty
good
um it was like a little bit on a little
on the high side
and then the term the greenhouse i guess
clean house effect was early 20th
century thank frank
the director of it's a wonderful life
had a documentary about climate change
in the 1950s
um so the level of concern was there
and
then you know scientific consensus was
the 60s and 70s
then it's like the 90s early 90s that
like the um
activism around climate change starts to
really happen and build up
and so when i think about
a.i and biowsk and so on i'm kind of
like it's like we're in the 1950s with
climate change okay and
uh there's actually a leading and so i'm
just like
yeah there's certain like scientific
technological facts
um that are just enormously important
people don't know them yet
we've got to build this movement this is
going to take time it's frustrating that
uh
you know i completely understand being
frustrated that's like
this is so big and people aren't
thinking about it
um
uh but i guess like i respond by that by
being like okay let's go let's see so
they've wet
are you kind of saying that climate
change and the activism around that is a
appetizer it's an aperitif
to
us coming in well dude
yeah exactly i i very much admire your
uh positive
optimistic outlook around it and
that that does
fill me with a little bit more hope the
fact that look people needed to
understand about the fragility of human
future
one of the ways that this got delivered
because it's very obvious you know smoke
in the sky
and fires and
heat and stuff right it's like it's
experiential
as opposed to
ai risk which is just code you can't see
until it's not
um so yeah maybe maybe maybe you're
right maybe maybe that's a a thing going
going back to what we spoke about before
so you've got extinction
but you've also got
unrecoverable global collapse
what's the difference between those two
things and how would a global collapse
happen
okay so
um
i said extinction seems pretty hard i
mean i still gave it 0.5 that's a lot
when you're talking about you know
that's only 0.5 over the next hundred
years it was twenty percent that's okay
oh yeah i mean no twenty percent was the
risk of some major
like hundreds of millions of dead kind
of level pandemic
um yeah i mean taylor like
still not good decide whether to trust
me or not but utterly terrifying i think
um
yeah so i mentioned like killing
literally everyone um okay that's like
uh
you know maybe that's you know low you
know low but very severely significant
likelihood
um a catastrophe that just set us back
to pre-industrial levels of technology
so killed 99 or 99.9 percent of the
world's population
at least you might think that might be
much more likely
and could occur from a very like could
also occur from pandemics and could
occur occur from an all-out nuclear war
that leads to nuclear winter um you know
perhaps could
occur via other means
um
would we get would we come back because
if
if not
then
the unrecovered collapse of civilization
would plausibly be
just as bad or almost as bad as
outright extinction you know we would
go to
like a farming society again or even
hunt together society limp along an
asteroid would you know
uh cause alone
you know wipe us out
um over it would just be a matter of
time essentially
and so i you know there hadn't been that
much work um before
before what we are the future on this
question of
how likely is a civilizational collapse
if there was one like would we actually
come back
and so i really wanted to do a deep dive
into this
and
really try to think that
yeah assess the
question of like well yeah would we come
back and if not why not and i actually
kind of came out pretty optimistic um
certainly over the course of doing the
search uh
for what we are the future i
came out being a lot more positive
thinking it's like well over 90 i think
that civilization would bounce back if
we move back to the industrial levels of
technology
and that's for the few reasons so one is
that
uh if you look at local catastrophes
they very rarely lead to collapse
i'm actually not sure if i even
know any examples
um
of
collapse in the relevant sense where
you take the fall of the roman empire
that was the collapse of a civilization
but firstly it was only local there's
never been a kind of global collapse of
civilization and secondly
it's not like people disappeared from
the region
it's just that like technology went
backwards for a while and um you know
other indicators of advanced
civilization kind of went back for a
while
whereas if you know we would be thinking
about that happening on global scale and
going to kind of pre-industrial levels
and so even if you take something like
the black death um
in europe which killed
somewhere between like
25 and 60 percent of the population of
europe
there wasn't civilizational collapse it
was like enormously tragic um
[Music]
with such a loss of life
but civilization kind of european
civilization kept going and in fact
there was the industrial revolution just
a few centuries later
um
and yeah in the book i discussed many
other ways in which
locally
um societies have like taken these
enormous knocks and then kind of bounced
back so give the example of hiroshima as
well where
again prior to the search i'd had this
image in my mind of hiroshima even now
it's just this like smoking ruin whereas
it's not true at all within 13 years the
population was back to
um
the population before it was um
uh had an atomic bomb slapped on it um
now it's this like flourishing city
so that's kind of one reason the second
is just how much uh
technology um that could be imitated or
information in libraries that people
could
use in order to like to you know make
technological advancement again
where
you know the early innovators they were
doing this from scratch there was
nothing to copy
whereas if you're like oh there's this
thing it seems to like burn
oil in order to like make a motor go
around like i want like maybe we can
copy this becomes like much easier
especially then there's materials in
libraries too
and then the final consideration is just
that um
uh
it
if you think if you try and just go
through a list of like what are the
things that could stop us
from getting to today's level of
technology again
you kind of come up short i think the
one that could
could be decisive is fossil fuels
um
where we've already kind of used up
easily accessible oil
and over the course of a few hundred
years we would use up easily accessible
coal
um but at least for the time being
we
have enough in the way of fossil fuels
that
even a catastrophe that sent us back to
even that sent us back to the stone age
we would cut we would come back and if
we were industrializing again we'd be
we'd have enough to get to today's level
of technology at least what's your idea
about coal mines and what we should do
with them
yeah so
um
in
in the book i talk about
uh
kind of clean tech in particular as this
like just very robustly good thing we
can do
um but the reasons for that aren't
always the most intuitive
so one
you know there are many reasons i think
for wanting to keep coal in the ground
climate change is one enormous health
pollution that air pollution and health
costs from burning fossil fuels um but
one is just we might need it in the
future
um if there's a catastrophe that sends
civilization back to
agricultural agricultural levels of
technology and we need to be
industrialized well we got to where we
are by burning prodigious amounts of
coal
um and we might need that again
uh and yet we're burning through it
and so yeah i think the best thing to do
is just invest in clean tech so that's
not just solar panels but also
alternative fuels
uh suit what's called super hot rock
geothermal where you drill just really
far into the ground and harness the heat
from
closer to the mantle
um but one idea that i looked into is
just can you just buy coal mines and
shut them down
um that was the kind of like no brain
like
take
um and like could you do this at scale
could you do this as a way of carbon
offsetting where
a large group of people get together
they all contribute to a fund that like
pays for the coal mine to be retired
um there are people looking into this um
uh and i commissioned some of the search
to look into it it seems pretty hard
unfortunately mainly for regulatory
reasons
um
where
uh governments
have
i mean they're just very powerful fossil
fuel lobbies and they don't like you
buying coal mines and shutting them down
so there's kind of use it or loser laws
where
if you try and buy a coal mine with the
purpose of shutting it down the
government just voids your contract
because they say if you buy a coal mine
you have to use the coal
and that i think you know even if you
can get around that that drives up the
price a lot more
um people perhaps just shift to other
calls so unfortunately i'm like a little
more negative on that particular
strategy than i used to be but
for the while i was just really taken
with it i just i just really loved this
idea of just like we own this coal mine
now we're gonna turn it into this museum
um a museum for obsolete technology and
it'll have like you can go around like a
theme park um
in the like uh the little trucks that
you see in indiana jones like going
along the carts um i had the whole
vision but uh maybe one day i'll still
do it we've gotta be the most impactful
thing we've got those seed banks right
there's is it in iceland i think or in
and so
that's it in norway and that's
a bunch of every
plant seed on the planet and presumably
there must be equivalent backups
digitally of every book probably
distributed across the world and they'll
be in underground bunkers or on the side
of a mountain or something like that so
that if there was some sort of huge
collapse or
any kind of existential risk that had a
bit of kinetic energy to it that it
would be it would be kept away and what
that does is it shortcuts the
pain and the investment that you need in
order to be able to actually find out
what to do you can just go back and read
what you need to do and then you get to
rediscover the technologies and i've
never heard anyone else talk about it
the fact that
one of the advantages we had was that
all of the coal and the oil was
relatively close to the surface and you
pick the by design you pick the low
hanging fruit first
but that doesn't future-proof you
against
uh
collapse recoveries potentially well
because if you do collapse and you need
to recover presumably you're going to be
able to get low-hanging fruit
but not the less the higher hanging
fruit so easily which means that you
actually need to keep that you need to
portion off a little bit in future i was
thinking about this as well
is there a reason or would there be a
justification
for
having a an
almost like an air-gapped civilization
somewhere on earth i know that we don't
we're not a multi-planetary species yet
so we haven't put somebody on mars and
maybe that would be one of the obvious
ways to do this but
to have
a selection of people with a wide
genetic pool and you've done the testing
on them and they go to a particular
place
and they are they live there for their
entire lives or perhaps you could do it
like military service and people could
cycle in and out and you would maybe go
for four years but what that's kind of
like as close to air gapping a backup
for civilization
behind the normal civilization that
we've got going on in the same way as
the seed bank or the same way as the
modern library of alexandria or whatever
we've got is there just is there a
justification for us sending some people
into the side of a mountain and making
them live there for ages
uh yeah absolutely um on your previous
point i just wanted to briefly mention
that the idea of harnessing the
low-hanging flute you know this is
historical counterfactual where if we
were to go if we were to collapse where
would the industrial revolution happen
and i can bet you my last dollar would
not happen in western europe
because we already used up all the
surface coal instead it would be in the
u.s or india or china or australia with
us with us more
um but okay civilizational backup
um
[Music]
this is not only i think a good idea um
it's something that
people who buy into the idea of
long-termism i think we really might
make happen so again with foundations i
advise it's um and philanthropists i
advise
uh
this is something we'd be pretty
interested in doing um
uh so
having
a hermetically sealed refuge
where
a certain number of people
um
stay in that for long periods of time
um yeah perhaps it's
six months at a time and kind of cycles
out perhaps it's like stage um there's a
couple of them and you do it
asynchronously
or perhaps it's even longer
um
that is completely protected against the
outside world so again if there's a
really worst case pandemic
then and it's you know we're not just
talking about um
hundreds of millions of people dying
here but literally it will kill everyone
well you have this population of let's
say a thousand people including leading
scientists who would be able to work on
you know medical countermeasures like
vaccines
and they would then be able to stay
there and you'd equip it such they could
stay there for years
design countermeasures so that when they
emerge
if they need to um they are protected
against the pathogens
uh
and then the second thing you would also
need to stock it such that it could um
rebuild society after that point
um this seems just like so wacky as an
idea to many people um but i think it
makes sense like
um
on the scale of
the whole of the world
you know we have a world gdp of close to
100 trillion dollars with 8 billion
people does it make sense to spend at
least a little bit of those resources
um
like you know a few hundred or a
thousand people to be just like
protected in case for the like fairly
worst case outcomes i think from that
perspective the answer seems like yeah
obviously yes
because
yeah even if it was a small population a
few hundred people that would be enough
uh to the you know to rebuild
civilization again and i think it's
worth preserving rob reed laughed at me
when i gave him that idea last year so
this is yeah i did i like it i think
it's a good i think it's a cool idea
but i think um it's interesting the
response that you know and i have it too
when you get confronted with
certain ideas that sound like the sci-fi
or something and you laugh at them but
that's just been true for many ideas in
the past like
um the idea that uh
viruses were carried by these little
monsters that live in your hands and
clone your skins like what this is
nonsense um yeah yeah it's true
the idea that we could fly
um you know build big metal planes and
take them into the skies like that was
pretty that was pretty wacky too
so i think we have this like you know
very natural human impulse to just laugh
at these like silly ideas but i think
when the stakes are this great we should
actually just be taking a little bit of
time to reflect and think okay does this
actually make good sense and i think in
this case it does
given everything that we've gone through
and the
potential
duration that we're moving towards for
our genetic inheritance and
civilizational future the risks that
we've got the way that we can mitigate
them how we can move back against them
what's the actual goal what what should
our goal
for the future of humanity be what do we
what are we even optimizing for
what we're building for so
i think the key thing i want to say is
that we don't know yet and that's okay
so
imagine you're a teenager
and you're wondering like oh what's the
goal of my life and you just want to be
as happy as possible let's say now you
might just not know yet you know and
what do you want to do
well
okay as a teenager you want to not die
because if you die then you're going to
um
uh you know you're not going to have a
flourishing life after that point um so
similarly we want to make sure we don't
occur extinct but then you just want to
have lots of possible futures open to
you and be able to have time to like
figure stuff out try things out see
what's actually is going to make
give you the most flourishing life
and that's okay so you can have a plan
that is about getting yourself to a
position such that you can figure out
what to do for the rest of your life and
i think the same is true for humanity as
a whole we want to we should try to get
ourselves to a state where
we are not facing existential
catastrophe
we are we do have many possible futures
open to us we're able to reflect and
deliberate um and then
make further moral progress so that we
can then collectively figure it out from
a place of kind of much more enlightened
much more enlightened these in
perspective what we should do with the
you know potentially vast future that's
ahead of us and i call these ideas this
idea of kind of exploring and trying to
figure out um different things a more a
morally exploratory society in the book
with the kind of
the limit case of that i call the long
the long reflection which is um
where it's like okay we've got to a
state where
uh we've kind of solved the most
pressing needs do we want to immediately
rush to just settling settling the stars
with um whatever our favorite model
views are i'm like no
we've got time
as we talked about the very start of
this podcast we've got an awful lot of
time
and that means we can before we engage
in any activities that lock in a
particular world view
such a speech settlement or formation of
a world government
then we really take the time to ensure
that we've gotten you know gotten to the
end of model progress that we've really
figured out all the way that we can
are you
of the mind that
we should move more slowly with moral
progress and our considerations for what
we should do
once we've got ourselves to
technological maturity
than in technological progress on route
to get there
uh
so
i think
with technological play with us how fast
we should go is kind of tough
um
where
you know there are these reasons i think
why at the moment
going faster technologically is like a
little better it's not kind of that big
a deal
i do think that if you can make model
progress
faster
you just want to go as fast as you can
because you make the everything better
than the future
it's just that i think that
real moral progress might take time
um so this might be true for
technological progress too maybe it
takes um
you know i've i've said that we can't go
as fast as we're currently going
but
assuming we slow perhaps the whole
project takes you know millions of years
to come i don't know
but the same might be true for morality
as well
and unlike
with technology there's always incentive
to build better technology it gives you
more power
um
it means you can do more things whatever
your values are
so there's like always strong incentives
to do that
with moral progress that's not true um
if i'm if i don't care if i have all the
power and i don't care about having a
better model point of view
there's no law of nature there's also no
real competitive dynamics that force me
to have get to a better moral
perspective
and
so
what i'm really doing and kind of
sketching out this idea of the long
reflection is just to be is to really
say
we need to keep working on
you know getting better models getting
better
values
uh
we don't want to just like jump into the
first thing that we think is good you
know early 21st century
western liberal-ish kind of modalities
like no let's like we can take up we can
take our time before engaging in kind of
any of these big
projects
there's less of a
um
degree of urgency with that although you
can go as quickly as you want you can
you can luxuriate and take your time
perhaps in a way that you couldn't do
with with technological change
i yeah i mean i think for the world as a
whole i think we could perhaps luxuriate
with
uh technological change at least and
if we get to a point of um
safety
so perhaps after the bio weapons you
know
within this aren't perhaps in this
unsustainable state at the moment but
perhaps we you know early
22nd century then uh maybe there aren't
any nuclear weapons now we've got great
detections against them and perhaps
we've not yet finished technological
progress but the particular level we're
in is actually really very safe and
stable maybe we just want to hang out
there for a little while
while we figure some model and political
stuff out um so this is kind of like
boston's thing about how you can have i
can't remember the the asymmetry in
terms of technological development but
you can also do this in terms of moral
versus technological development that
you can kind of keep on idling while you
continue to move on forward and then
let's say that you have your technology
that allows you to catch up to that i
think it's was eric weinstein that said
uh where gods were just shitty gods it's
bostrom that was talking about like
where gods but for the wisdom and
that yeah exactly we want to have yeah
we want to accelerate wisdom as much as
we can it just seems good in general
um
and then
like i say i think that the particular
circumstances at the moment that do mean
that like
ensuring we keep tech progress going um
like is good as well but if you could
guarantee me guarantee me that look even
at a slower rate
just now without like point five percent
growth per year point one percent growth
per year but we're going to get moral
progress along the same time then that
would you know and assuming the tech
focus is not going to stagnate but just
continue with that lower rate
um
you know then i'd feel pretty good about
that how do you speed up moral progress
have you thought about that
uh i mean one is by
very hard questions so one is having
like
uh
kind of diversity of model views
um
and even societies as well
so
there was this kind of you know great
ideal behind the united states that
never really happened of all the
different states would be like this
violent different culture
and uh there'd be like a laboratory of
democracy and instead it just like
united states became a relatively
uniform country
um but you could like aim for
um
a kind of global society that was like
more like that
um i think we can also just invest more
in
and obviously
i don't talk about this that much
because it sounds so incredibly
self-serving as a model do you want to
be more philosophers to be invested in
yeah i think we should like
how much of what the world society of uh
other sources gets spent on um
you know and not just model philosophy
but other humanities um
uh you know capacity for
building capacity for empathy and so on
but really the amount we spend in a
society is like vanishingly small like
0.01 even on all of the humanities as a
whole
and
that's like in your own life
oh how much time should i spend figuring
out where how i spend the entire rest of
my life as a teenager
oh yeah maybe i'll spend like a day on
it and that'll do it's like i don't know
it doesn't make sense you're talking
about your entire life
similarly with humanity as a whole
you know
if it were the case the kind of moral
reflection and reasoning
and
progress in the model domain
had
a hundredth
of the status of prestige and investment
that technology does
even though it's the model progress
that's contingent not the technological
progress so actually it's the moral
progress that we should be trying to
safeguard even more
um
well yeah then we would have to increase
the number of model philosophers like a
thousand-fold
um and honestly i think it'd be a very
good thing um
but yeah perhaps there's some bias there
it would make my job a lot easier on the
podcast as well that would be a good
exercise exactly what happened so yeah
and also include the quality as well you
wouldn't be getting idiots like me you'd
be getting them
the very best people who are otherwise
going into maths and physics would be uh
working on uh improving our model
understanding will mccaskill ladies and
gentlemen if people have been compelled
by the stuff that you've spoken about
today and they want to find out more or
work out how they could contribute to
making our future a little bit less
terrible where should they go
uh so
obviously um love you to read the book
that i just wrote what we are the future
um
which i think will be out at this uh
when the podcast is launched um but then
if you want to take action uh two big
ways to take action one is through
donations and i co-founded an
organization called giving what we can
that encourages people to give at least
10 percent of their income to the
organizations that are most effective
and
you can contribute to organizations that
are trying to prevent the next pandemic
or that are trying to safely guide the
development of artificial intelligence
um or prevent a third world war um and
thereby
barely significantly impact the
trajectory of human civilization
the second thing big thing you can do is
uh
try and think about how you can use your
career to do good in the world maybe
you're already established um perhaps
you're a podcast host and you should
think about how can you get the
um you know
most uh important messages out there or
you might be early on in your career and
trying to figure out yeah what should
the trajectory of my life be i
co-founded another organization 80 000
hours
and
it has enormous amounts of advice all
for free online to try to help people
make the best career decisions so they
can have the biggest impact in
particular biggest impact on issues that
impact uh the long-term future and help
build a better world for future
generations um they have online advice
they have a podcast eighty thousand
hours podcast uh and they also offer
free one on one um advice as well so
yeah check out both giving what we can
and eighty thousand hours and uh my book
what we are the future too
uh and
take that all into account you can make
a truly enormous difference to the world
for
thousands millions or even billions of
years to come
well i appreciate you man i love the
work that you guys do
uh if this is the history of the future
or the beginning of the history of the
future or whatever i'm glad that we've
got people like you that are guiding us
in whatever way you can
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
you